woman: So could you start off by introducing your company and give me a bit of an overview of your application and
your motivations behind creating it?
Francisco Tolmasky: Sure, my company is called 280 North. We actually have two products that use the Google APIs, the
first one is called 280 Slides,
It's kind of like powerpoint or keynote on the web and the other is a opensource framework called cappucino for
creating applications like 280 Slides.
woman: So tell me a bit about how you chose to use the Open Web for your app.
Francisco: Sure, I mean it was pretty clear from the beginning that we wanted to do web based applications, since it's
the best distribution platform there is. And the Google APIs in particular allowed us to use a lot of existing
services in particular we use both google images and the youtube apis to allow people to bring in rich media into
their slides and applications.
woman: So, do you have any war stories that you can share with us?
Francisco: Uh, actually, interestingly enough, the war stories are not so much about the Google APIs in general, but
having to use a number of APIs because
we also use, like, Flickr APIs, and obviously they're designed differently than the Google ones, so it was kind of
unfortunate that we had to have two separate code bases. So often times, when we would use one set of APIs, we were
thinking, like, the other ones, then that would lead to some interesting stories.
woman: So if you could snap your fingers today and instantly have some sort of key web standard or feature available
across all browsers today, what would that be?
Francisco: Canvas. Easily. That's an easy question.
woman: Why canvas?
Francisco: Uh, because it's, I think the last remaining component to fully being able to do just about everything from
the desktop on the web. Just being able to have pixel-level control completely changes the space.
woman: So what part of HTML5 are you most excited about?
Francisco: i think i'm most excited about, well, canvas but also web workers. I think, you know, the ability to
have... kind of... threads is really exciting.
Obviously one of the big problems today is that the heavy JavaScript locks up the UI, and being able to put stuff off
on a web worker is really exciting.
woman: So, how does what you're doing now fit into the Open Web?
Francisco: So our main product is a web product, and the framework that we're developing is for developing
applications on the Open Web. So they're kind of exactly aligned, uhm, and specifically-- the reason we designed our
framework-- is to allow people to use open standards and open technologies and have a solid framework such as .NET or
Cocoa that they already have on the desktop, but on the web.
woman: So where do you think the web should go in general, what are some significant problems that haven't been solved
yet?
Francisco: I would very much like to see a lot more low-level control. I think web workers and canvas are a good start
to this, but up to now the trend with the web has been... kind of... enabling specific features as opposed to specific
abilities. Like, css has always been about-- if you want to do this kind of layout, use this feature-- as opposed to
just having really low level control, being able to do everything you can on the desktop.
woman: So what do you most need from AJAX and HTML?
Francisco: Uh, for it to get faster.
[laughter]
woman: Faster? That's it? Just faster faster faster?
Francisco: Yes that's it. That's basically the number one thing that we want.
woman: that's cool. So, have you learned anything at I/O that you're really excited about?
Francisco: Uh, yeah. I got to learn a lot about the Android platform. which I actually didn't know anything about
before. And I got a free phone so I can actually start developing for it, and that's exciting, uhm, and yeah, a lot of
HTML5 stuff I got to learn more in depth, so...
woman: That's cool. Well, thank you for coming to talk to us.
Francisco: thank you.